so remember the stunt Donald Trump
pulled Sunday showing up at a church and
the White House said that he showed up
to pray for the victims of the shooting
the mass shooting that took place in
Virginia last week or on Friday last
Friday President Trump showed up to a
church and it was apparently not as the
pastor is now reporting they did not
show up to pray for the victims of the
mass shooting but instead to pray for
the President himself you have to be
some kind of scumbag to lie about the
reason that you're praying especially
when you're supposed to be praying for
the victims I mean the all Republicans
do in a mass shooting or after a mass
shooting is to all four thoughts and
prayers but apparently the President of
the United States isn't even offering
prayers genuinely here's a quote from
the article in The Huffington Post says
quote a pastor's explanation of
President Donald Trump Trump's sudden
visit to his church on franklin graham's
pray for Donald Trump's day is casting
doubt on the White House it's widely
publicized claim that he went there to
pray for Friday's shooting victims in
Virginia Beach David Platt pastor of
McLean Bible Church a few miles from
Trump's Golf Course in Northern Virginia
wrote in a statement that he first heard
about Trump's visit after he finished
his sermon early Sunday afternoon so
much to unpack there that's actually
worthwhile first of all why in the hell
are we having a national pray for Trump
day that I can write an entire book
about why not only is that problematic
but it's also it's also just a tool to
rally evangelical voters to the
Republican Party and and it's been this
this symbiotic relationship between the
evangelical church and republicanism
since Ronald Reagan actually did write a
book about it now think about it
God is not a Republican but that that
part setting that part aside the fact
that the president was still in his golf
outfit his golf clothes and and he
wished then really quick to get a
photo-op praying for the victims of the
mass shooting
but it ended up just turning out to be a
prayer for him I mean there's layers and
layers of hypocrisy it's already in the
story but I want to read one more
paragraph from Huffington Post it said
quote the White House though had given a
different reason for the visit just as
Trump was walking into the church the
press office sent out a statement
claiming that he was there to visit the
pastor and pray for the victims and
community of Virginia Beach yet during
the entirety of Trump's 16 minutes Dave
Platt the pastor did not mention the
shooting and Trump never spoke about the
shooting or anything else beyond
thanking Platt afterwards so I mean I
guess you could chalk this up and say it
was just oh it's just a miscommunication
they didn't really convey the reason
that they were there I mean if you want
to be generous sure you can talk that up
and but but why does it matter it
matters because it's consistent it's a
very consistent theme with Donald Trump
and Republicans and conservatives in
general all for different reasons it's a
it's a it's a consistent theme with
Donald Trump to be a habitual liar
right he lies about everything but
particularly he lies about his religion
and his faith and he presents himself or
you know let me take that back
evangelicals tried to present Donald
Trump as some type of reverent pious
person who is ordained by God to fix
America when a reality Trump is just
aligned
well we're on David show so I can't use
profanity but Trump is an outright liar
about his belief system about politics
about his ego I mean it there's no facet
of Donald Trump's life that he is not
compelled to lie about and and so this
is just a really consistent theme with
Donald Trump he's also opportunistic I
mean he literally still had on his golf
shoes you know coming in whisking in the
church there was a paragraph that I
wanted to read but the church is
actually the closest church to the golf
course so he didn't really say okay I'm
going to go to Virginia so that I can
pray for these people what actually had
and was he realized or an assistant
realized that Donald Trump is in
Virginia and in Virginia Beach and he's
not there on behalf of the victims he's
there to play golf how do we fix it
well you have some enterprising
assistant who says okay what we can do
is let's shoot over to the local church
and say a prayer for the victims but
they didn't relay that information to
the pastor see how that works so not
only does Donald Trump a liar he's
opportunistic and and really quite
frankly did not care about those victims
enough to realize that he was in
Virginia and hadn't really done anything
but except go golfing and then somebody
tried to fix a problem ultimately making
the problem even worse the story is also
significant because of what I was
discussing with Franklin Graham with the
evangelical movement absolutely trying
to spin Donald Trump to be something
more than this this this I really only
have a religious word this is lascivious
this this disgusting man who was driven
by nothing but his ego and his passions
who is the exact opposite of everything
evangelicals preach Donald Trump is the
exact opposite of everything that
evangelicals preach but because he is
their political tool Donald Trump is
their political pawn they're willing to
give him a mulligan to use some golf
tournament Ehrman ology they're willing
to give him a mulligan to forget about
all of the different ways Donald Trump
demonstrates that he is absolutely the
opposite of anything Jesus would have
been or do but evangelicals don't care
about that they care about their
political agenda most of their political
agenda is about taking away a woman's
right to choose attacking the LGBTQ
community of marriage equality they
don't care about anything else but those
things they don't care about any other
form of morality they don't care about
economic justice they don't care about
oppression and what capitalism does to
poor people they don't care about
children after they're born they don't
care about any of that Donald Trump is
great to them because Donald Trump gives
them an opportunity to do everything
they want on particularly on taking away
a woman's right to choose so as far as
evangelicals are concerned don't
Trump probably could shoot somebody on
Fifth Avenue and still be one of their
favorite presidents and the last thing
and not to not to belabor the point too
much but this idea of praying for the
president when in fact the last
administration they prayed against the
president shows the hypocrisy that
they're not operating in terms of any
sense of real any real sense of faith
and being concerned about the leadership
of our country they're only concerned
about the leadership of this country
that serves their political interest if
you love learning new things you
probably want to check this out the
David Pakman show today is sponsored by
Skillshare and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy to use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job
I've gotten a ton out of it Pat has
taken some courses that he's found
really valuable and I think you'll love
it to get started for free by clicking
the link under this video